thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a
heartwarming wild ride with Stevo yeah
man you wouldn't expect to feel so good
on this one but man get ready to because
this is a guy Dane Cook who really
looked out for me man really took me
under his wing really helped me out and
uh I mean I'm just happy to call him a
friend we have great laughs we reveal a
lot of Juicy interesting stuff and it
just makes you feel good you know what
else makes me feel good man my mattress
right here on my tour bus if you lay
down on that bed over there you're not
going to want to get off of it why
because it came from Helix
sleep.com and when you go to
helixsleep.com
Stevo you get up to 200 off of every
mattress order and with every mattress
order they throw in two free pillows and
I don't know if you've heard um
statistics on bed bugs mites stuff like
this disgusting mattresses it's
important to change your mattress and
it's important to get it from
helixsleep.com because when you get
there you take very simple two minute
quiz and they match you up with the
ideal mattress for you and you might not
even know what the ideal mattress for
you is unless you go to
helixsleep.com
Stevo for that up to 200 off of any
mattress order and two free pillows they
hooked me up on my tour bus at my house
at my warehouse I only sleep on
mattresses from Helix sleep.com and you
should too so jump on that deal and
let's get into it
God damn it
I'll figure it out you have any glue
these [ __ ] you have an electrician
mini like what's keyed in with me glue
kind of glue Elmer's ah crazy girl
gorilla
somebody hit me with another glue and
I'll [ __ ] give you ten thousand
dollars cash I have it in my car ah
crazy clip no we won't I always see you
said CREAM [ __ ]
here we go ah you know what it's close
enough whatever like that I think that's
is that legal I think that looks great
Wendy you happy with that
ladies and gentlemen Dane Cook yeah dude
what's up man so you met Scott yep my
co-host yeah
um
this is a long time coming man like you
were one of the first guys that I wanted
to get on here
um
because you've been so generous with
your time with your support and um
really without you I would not have
launched into
uh a comedy career the way that I did
and have you ever do people really know
like how that kind of transpired and
where we ended up yapping well I never
shut up about it
I've heard I've heard fragments and flex
and I was always like so moved that you
acknowledge that you know we had that
time but I don't know if I've ever
really held court with you to talk about
like how that night was meaningful for
both of us because I was also in a very
convoluted place in my life and time wow
yeah I mean just to give people The
Cliff Notes um it was when the first
tiny Rumblings of the press machine uh
revved up for
the Jackass 3D movie yeah that movie
came out and I want to say October but
we're back like a few months before that
and uh like maybe August maybe even July
2010 2010 and I showed up for this uh
young Hollywood at the Four Seasons
Hotel they had a whole Suite rented out
using it as a studio they were cycling
people through doing interviews and when
I showed up for mine they said oh dude
Dane Cook's in there go ahead and just
barge right into his interview it'll be
hilarious yeah so I walk in by the way
we found footage of this too they say
barged by the way that's usually not the
word that they tee you up with right hey
you should pop in and say hi but usually
maybe for you it's barged yeah so I know
when I sit down it was the first time we
ever met it was uh you know a pleasant
experience and I said you know dude Dane
I've done stand up a couple times and
and it's something I really want to dive
into and you said great cool next week
we're gonna jump on stage and like I
figured after the interview was over
maybe like you would just you know it
was great to say that on camera but sure
enough flip service Hollywood yeah when
the cameras I got enough of it to know I
didn't want to be that but yeah when the
cameras were no longer rolling you you
were like yeah seriously man here let me
give you my number and let's plan this
out yeah because I I quickly identified
something that we talked a little bit
about which was
I knew a lot of people that were very
talented that wanted to figure out how
to uh recalibrate to stand up and
sometimes in the community that's like
really frowned upon for whatever reason
they think this is what they think a lot
of people in the community you're a
really good drummer but you want to play
guitar who the [ __ ] do you think you are
right and I assume if you're good at one
instrument you're probably good at
entertaining people maybe in a couple of
other instruments and I had also gone
through the same thing of like I came up
I came up in kind of like a way that I
broke ahead of a pack
and because I was using this new social
media element I was somehow not
legitimate I was hitting a button and Ah
that's interesting circumventing so by
the time this dude comes in the door and
I'm a bit of an energy Vibe guy myself I
was like oh I I identify that
I know where this guy's at and also I'd
known like guys like Bert Kreischer who
I was telling you I sat at hojos in
Times Square in 95 and he was coming out
of a time when he was the Rolling Stones
The Machine Party the comics were being
shitty to him like he's not one of us
he's not legit he came from a hype
article or something so
I was like I just I I was like I'm a fan
and I I felt like
you were really sincere in that moment I
wanted to just return that sincerity
well yeah I appreciate it so much and I
remember
every bit of it like I spent in the next
week just writing material I was even
going to like these hole in the wall
open mics to practice it I I was uh you
know rehearsing it writing it rewriting
spent that whole week just like coming
up with this crappy little set and um
you know we showed up at the the uh
Hollywood improv you went on and I think
it was like Sarah Silverman and then you
and then me and I just couldn't have
been more nervous I did my set I
remember uh
my first joke was um I've been clean and
sober since Johnny Knoxville pulled an
intervention on me and you know you have
a problem when your interventionist is
Johnny Knoxville and uh you know
it was what it was you know I did this
thing and then what was crazy was that
after which which for me it was funny
well not only funny but like my brain
always goes to like if there's truth in
your whatever
I respond to that even more than if you
said something very funny that was only
observational like response is the
response but like you're saying
something really real within a shell of
something humorous so that was cool
that's that's how it's been like all
along it's just been like 100 like my my
reality you know how how comedians get
pissed when you come on and become a
comedian from acting do do actors get
pissed when you are a comedian then you
become an actor I mean is it kind of the
same thing are they like hey welcome No
in fact like when I just very quickly
when I dovetailed into some dramatic
stuff or stuff away from Comedy they
were if anything people were excited
like oh you're going to bring an element
to this scene or this script that's
crazy maybe we didn't you're doing
something dramatic but if we need
something comedic they kind of look to
you go like you you probably have an
idea but the comedy world as you now
know
um you know there's a lot of thorn
patches and there's you know it's more
competitive than what you would see
exterior as far as like you think it's a
community of just funny people just
it's just not right I wanted it to be
that too for the longest time but it's
just not and so you can find when you
find somebody who Keys into you and is
like
take a breath you know come back you
know somebody said to me really recently
dude I've been getting beat up by so
many kind of comics and you know I think
I'm I'm gonna quit I was just like just
do me a favor don't quit tonight okay
yeah based on this conversations give it
give it another night give it one more
shot you'll feel a little differently
with some new inspiration or whatever
but that moment and two years later have
you and I talk about it and acknowledge
it I'm just I said it last night man I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you look what
you've done you're so entrepreneurial
and I'm sure a lot of those people that
maybe or maybe not are in your book or
um are probably thinking like man I wish
I had been more of a friend of that guy
so Dane's the reason why I have a tour
managing job too yeah well
thank you yeah
also real quick before you tell me that
story I'm the one who released Wendy
had dogs out of the van maybe they found
love in Peru and so Wendy you're welcome
and Scott yeah yeah wait what no no I
missed I'm his tour manager and so like
uh that he he brought me on like nine
years ago so got it because by proxy it
was like okay that's cool that's very
nice man I love that yeah so I do the
first set and now keep in mind Dane did
his set then he introduced me and then I
did my set oh we were tag team yeah oh
[ __ ] okay he brought me on and uh it was
vicious cruelty like I had left uh I I
had left a bottle of water on the piano
at The Improv and you're like you're
like does anybody like have a like a
hazmat suit to remove this something
rather like anybody want herpes that it
was it was it was it was it like every
like without fail like on stage Dane
would be like just vicious yeah amazing
of love that you only get from a comic
that really cares about you that's cool
but then he gets off stage watches me
perform my set actually Karen to pay
attention to it and then when I got off
stage we sat down in the restaurant and
joining The Improv and I'll never forget
it like I sat down and Dane said
all right I'm not sending you back to
the drawing board and I was like
processing I was like like wait okay so
like the he said what I'm concerned with
is your your delivery you know more than
your material your material is like
working you know just uh you're so like
tense and like you know nervous and I'm
like well [ __ ] I was nervous you know
like thank God yeah if my cat was
nervous he was like I need you to relax
I need to relax you know relax did you
film it yeah I just like just relax you
know I'd like be more conversation right
be more conversational and since you're
right you don't have to be the thing
people know of you or think you are you
you have to have some Showmanship but I
was really just trying to tell them like
dude you're [ __ ] revved yeah get
revved years ago Metallica said when
somebody asks why why are you now doing
more ballads he goes the hard stuff
rocks harder when you slow it down a
beat and it was like I took that into
consideration in my own career and I
think I was trying to let you know that
like you can't come out of the Gated
[ __ ] well yeah and it was you said
you wanted to that
seem to be conversational like let it
don't make it be so much of a
performance but rather that you're
talking like yeah natural remember the
audience yeah trying to tell you like
you can build into performance pieces
but sometimes like in the own narration
of your act you gotta like that's when
you can like cool down a little bit when
we were set I I did that was a Wednesday
night and uh and I was just so energized
that you had been been supportive that
that you had been uh you know like like
what you told me put so much wind in my
sails that I arranged for that Friday
night two nights later to be at the
Laugh Factory to you know to go work on
this material some more yeah yeah and it
just so turned out that uh
it was you and then it was me we
repeated the same exercise so after
myself put him on after me I wanted to
learn everything all at once yeah
that night I come off stage and and we
sit down together and you said okay now
you're too relaxed now you just look
straight back is that now you're like
straight [ __ ] lethargic you gotta
remember this is a performance you know
like you got to be an animated version
of yourself right because I was trying
to relax you're like relaxing too much
and and it was uh then the next night
Saturday night we [ __ ] did it again
it was like this this uh every [ __ ]
night on you know we did it regularly
yeah we did and you always took the time
to to watch my [ __ ] and sit down and
give me notes and it meant the world it
truly did mean the world to me to have
Dane Cook pay attention and care about
me getting into stand up and it also
meant the world to me that he sent me
this special link to watch the special
that he just taped in his house man I
loved it the story about the stalker
that he dealt with is uh it's it's
equally funny as it is scary and I
really recommend checking it out you
know what else I recommend is taking
care of your health man your diet your
your gut health your brain you know how
I do that with athletic greens ag1 from
athletic greens it's comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition and it's
delicious you put a scoop of it into a
pint of water in the morning that gets
you hydrated that fills in the gaps in
your diet if you're not eating enough
greens and I am guilty of that from time
to time man it helps like like I said
with your gut health with your cognitive
abilities it's uh it's just really good
for you athletic
greens.com and why is it so good because
because it's loaded with 75 different
vitamins minerals Whole Food sourced
superfoods adaptogens probiotics it's
got it all and man it's really a good
idea for you to try it if you go to
athleticgreens.com Stevo they're going
to give you five comprehensive
convenient travel packs with all the
nutrition you need for those five days
plus an entire year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin D that is if you go to
athleticgreens.com Stevo you're gonna
get that with your first order so why
not jump on this deal one more time go
to athleticgreens.com Devo and let's get
back to it
hardest
um part about like when your comic
especially once you know you've made it
and people go like what should I do and
my whole thing is like it's not so much
me telling you I'm trying to always
protect your integrity when I Mentor
even Comics now I'm like I'm not going
to tell you how to be funny I'm not
going to tell you to take that out or
add that in I'm just going to try to
help you to figure out in some way the
fundamentals
to get to whatever the truth is that you
are because that's what they're going to
respond to even more than the jokes
believe it or not the jokes are not what
they're it's musicality
it's I've got a secret
I'm gonna let you know what it is in a
second hold up there's a lot of hype
there's a lot of things happening under
the surface I came up watching a guy
Johnny Carson on The Tonight Show when a
joke went bad
that's when he was [ __ ] amazing when
the crowd didn't react
the facial expression like dude it was
like oh that's where you're alive not in
the formulaic stuff that you've prepared
yeah in the moments that something
happened somebody drops the glass and
then maybe somebody gets to know you
within that moment so I was getting to
see you in real time and again like I I
want to be like um
recognizing pretty quick that like I
really wanted to give you some genuine
love and friendship I just felt
something from you maybe I even probably
knew a little bit of your story to
understand kind of like where you were
coming from but I remember night tonight
whenever we could shoot the [ __ ] about
it I was always like my goal tonight
with Stevo
um middle name Gilchrist yeah dude is I
always wanted to call him that by the
way I was like okay
um was to try to tell him a little
something that I recognized that was
good and maybe something that was like
all right that needs a little bit yeah I
mean because let's be clear like I I was
doing this basically for the first time
yeah it was I wasn't destroying he was
floundering no no no he was he was he
was recognizable and it was like they he
had a lot more work to do than somebody
who's brand new yeah because they had
assumptions he made me go up in front of
2 000 people foreign
will film the entire thing yeah baby
you're saying that at that time that you
were in in uh yeah would you say a
convoluted Place yeah here's what you
didn't know which was like 2010
okay so like
quick version was like I gone through
like the death of both of my parents
right around 0.506 and then I go through
this terrible situation with my brother
I had to put my brother in prison for
let's just say bad management yeah we
didn't want to bring it up yeah it's
okay I mean like if I bring it up it
means like I'm cool to talk about it
kind of thing
and then I went through the cooldown of
my peer everything was coming like the
period of cooldown in a career
and that was at the end of it and then I
was also getting smashed by Comics that
now I can say at 50 what I probably
couldn't say then without maybe looking
bad like a lot of jealousy a lot of
animosity that I
at a young age was famous hanging around
with beautiful women rich and there was
a lot of and I learned years later and I
can actually confirm that a lot of these
same people came to me years later I was
like I was just really [ __ ] like I
was frustrating I wanted to have more of
what you got anyway I mean do you were
selling out it was a 10-year run man it
was 10-year run of like every thing I
could have wanted to have happened in
the world of stand up and then all these
things Beyond it and by 10 2010
I was like
you know what I never want to do to
other Comics especially because I love
comedy and comedians but I was so hurt
by them I was so [ __ ] like let down
in some ways by the comedy community not
the guys I came up with that came up
Burr Patrice Goldman Bobby Kelly like I
had a pod of love from the graduating
class but
Beyond it there were so many like
preconceived notions of who I was and I
was getting at first it was a little fun
because you're like oh I'm kind of like
I'm the Target and then it got like kind
of ugly and then then things were like
unnecessarily pinned On Me by 2010 I was
so
um hurt in like disenfranchised that I
was like I could either go into myself
and just like take what I've earned and
go somewhere and be like [ __ ] everybody
I was like or I can just like for the
next generation of comics not be that
which was to me and that was a major
moment in my life where I was like I
truly felt after talking to him and then
a couple of times later being like
I'm gonna do this for everybody I can I
make myself available as I'm not really
quite a mentor I'm not at that age yet
but like I'm not gonna [ __ ] reject
anybody the way I've been rejected
and I don't to this day and that's why
we got to Cheers on it last night to be
like dude yeah you know we overcame a
lot of uh slings and arrows to be
in a very healthy and you know
well-adjusted spot man yeah how can you
say you're not a mentor you were the
you're the best of the best teaching
people like that's a mentor right and
what age do you think you become a
mentor at I don't think I was ready to
um I don't I don't think at that period
if you'd given me any other award to say
like now you're in now you're a provider
of this yeah I was actually rejecting
certain things that I was earning with
my hard work because I was like I'm so
tired of being a Target I don't I just
don't even want any Spotlight on me at
this time I was actually rejecting
certain
places where I probably would have
enjoyed myself more because I literally
was like just tired of the spanking
machine that I was dealing with and it
took a lot of great you know reflection
great therapy to finally know like oh no
I know what my purpose I know where my
place is then and I definitely know
where my place is now
it gets tired shoveling money all day
I hired somebody to do it what do you
think I shoveled my own money sadly it
was his brother
that was that was more like a that was a
plow yeah I wish it was just a shovel
yeah that was gnarly you were uh like
the like if I'm not mistaken the most
prolific uh Myspace
uh what do you call it like uh Tom
yeah I mean you were like yeah
1.0 is like Myspace right yeah the first
place to go viral really was Myspace
right I mean how big of of uh
like Catalyst for your comedy was the
Myspace it was like okay so leading up
to
um Myspace was like I see this internet
thing happening I'm on things like AOL
instant messenger and I'm trying to
share my screen name I'm kind of seeing
like oh wow this is like I'm finding
people like somebody in South Dakota is
like I'm following you and I was like
that's kind of cool I don't think I'll
ever go there maybe I don't know if I'll
ever tour there I'm writing this person
I'm doing that for a couple years and
then Myspace hits and I'm like let me
put on a page and Link everybody on that
uh instant messenger which now you'd say
DM right and I'll put it all on there
and I kind of had a hub
I invited everybody on there within a
couple of weeks I had 2 500 people now
here's what's funny the week the month
before
I was in a rut that was super miserable
I literally called my mother I was like
I don't know why I'm even out here
anymore because everything I thought was
going on is not in LA in LA in La yeah a
couple things that I thought were like
sparkly dulled and I had a couple of
little hits on TV but for the most part
except for doing College gigs
um Hollywood was not saying like you
you're up it was like no we already have
somebody kind of sort of like you
and I brought no data really I didn't
have a TV show nothing successful except
like I could show you receipts of Tour
tickets
so I'm like she my mom and I talk and
she's like
why don't you just keep doing that thing
where you're like you know conversating
with people that's kind of unique that's
kind of cool and I was like yeah this
new thing Myspace I get on there I take
my 2500 people and one night I come home
from the Laugh Factory and I spend the
whole night I think I probably respond
to 2500 people like welcome to the by
their name hey Carla in we're in Iowa I
sought your birthday last week happy
birthday here's a link and I start
sending people I spend the whole night a
link to it like some comedy MP3 comedy I
uploaded song excerpt right
a couple days later I'm dating this girl
Cassidy I remember Cassidy comes down
into the office and she hears me
laughing and she's like she comes down
she's like what's up and I was like this
I go look at this I go it's 3 800 people
and like what are 12 hours and now these
new people like I just got your link and
I'm watching three weeks later it's
um six thousand or seven thousand
that same girlfriend who walks in and
she goes
keep in mind I was miserable what five
weeks before like
no clue what my path forward was and I'm
sitting with my arms behind my head I'm
just like sitting in my [ __ ]
underwear with some fruit loops and I'm
just I'm looking at the computer she
goes what is going on in here I go
I'm about to take over the world
because you are and I was like I this
nobody realizes and I was telling people
I wasn't even keeping it like covert I
was going to the club do this right try
this out and those same Comics uh we're
gonna go party we're you know kind of
dismiss me I go home every night for
four years I shook every hand digitally
with every fan and sent links to pretty
much every single person until I had
millions of followers and could not do
it anymore man and Madison Square Garden
one click
two shows sold out one click I'm there
on this date
and after that Nothing Was the Same
again in my life how many people shows
up at Madison Square Garden two shows of
yeah a little eighteen five or something
like that in the round though is like
full like almost twenty thousand it was
called The Vicious Circle that was the
rough around yeah Vicious Circle Vicious
Circle was fast and what were you doing
before medicine like how big a venue
before that like before that college
gigs like I kind of hit like a maybe 25
2800 so you went from 2800 21
maybe like a three or four thousand
ready then Penn State which I I started
filming everything for what was then
known as webisodes you know like little
Clips excerpts and so I was I brought a
camera crew and I filmed a one month of
touring with Bobby Kelly Gary gallman
Jay Davis and I filmed something that I
thought was just gonna be free webisodes
and ended up getting vicious circle from
HBO Chris albrech was it at HBO offered
me my first special he's like what are
you gonna do I go I'm gonna do this tour
and try to drum up some more fans by the
time I got to Penn State
they called me up it was supposed to be
3 800 4 000 people they said we just
moved your show to the field house 12
000 people are here and I filmed it so I
have that night on film I go and I see
Chris Albrecht he goes what are you
gonna do now that you're done with the
tour I said I got 400 hours of footage
for [ __ ] free episodes that I need to
edit and he goes pop one in I had him in
a duffel bag I throw it in
Chris albrech HBO he goes this is like a
show
yeah I go all right we didn't film like
a show we just filmed everything he goes
cut it up into Eight Episodes I'll buy
this right now we'll put this on call it
whatever you want to call it tourism
yeah and then it aired before Vicious
Circle did you do that with uh New Wave
slash comedy that's right well I was
with Barry Katz at the time and I think
he had folded into that company right
yeah yeah it was right around that time
I think they they joined forces because
I remember being at New Wave and seeing
that yeah it was right around that time
but I was already like honestly My
Philosophy was already so different from
a traditional business route that even
then I was
already looking and thinking like I
don't want to depend on I could do this
myself people they were asking me what
to do because I knew more about tech
probably similar to the way you are now
I'm asking you questions now going like
hey who do you use for your blah blah
it's like I was in the know when nobody
else really well by the way he wants to
set up his uh
merge operation not merch operation I
don't know we didn't talk about merch
but his uh eventually special
we had this great oh yeah yeah we had
this great conversation at dinner last
night about owning our own [ __ ] yeah
that's the future yeah 100
000 yeah yes and we don't even need to
get into it but I've read every deal
every contract and I think we can all
agree well yeah like if you can do it
yourself you should we'll say we have a
we have a friend that has a cooking show
that's killing it and then the Food
Network approaches them and they're like
okay we'll offer you this it's like half
of what he's making and he can't say the
F word
it's like
why would I go with you like yeah we
don't know why you would want to go with
that I just don't like in stand up where
you they want to take a piece and then
they go can you take this line out can
you change this yeah can you open with
this instead and it's like no and
they're not even comedians right and
you're like no yeah you I get it and you
don't
and especially like Live Comedy that you
film then when it goes on television
it's like that's not the same show it's
it's absolutely completely different
because the energy is different from a
viewing audience at home so you need to
actually know
when you're even filming it this is how
I want it interpreted later like you're
already thinking of you should be
thinking of like the edits and the cuts
and I know how this should be presented
so even more so like get your hands off
this I know what my fans of however many
years are interested in so
I just hope it's ushering in a new era
now with what we're doing right and so
now would be a autonomy that would be a
great time to talk about your most
recent special yeah
which uh has had its two it was a
two-week window for uh the platform
called moment
I think by the time peop your fans see
this uh it'll be probably on
danecook.com but it's on moment now
still in that two-week window I extended
it a little bit because we're having a
good run and then it'll go back to my
website probably again I don't know
where this airs but anytime right now
it'll be at danecook.com this airs on
this is live one week from tomorrow a
week from tomorrow will be the October
26th it'll be the last day of moment and
then it reverts back to me okay yeah now
what like uh help us understand the
difference if you're a fan yeah trying
to consume your special do people look
at their watches and say wow they got
this the day it came out dude hurry up
to get the moment maybe like what's the
difference and yeah the whole thing with
moment that really I thought was so
ideal was it reminded me of like a
modern day pay-per-view you know like
the internet version of it to where it's
like all right you have a special online
people want to come in but you want them
to see it the way you want to see it in
real time and you also don't want to not
get the most important part which is the
data of who's watching my special and
this is where you lose across the board
outside of your own website or a place
like moment which is if you do a
streamer any streamer they will not let
you know numbers retention retention
region demo nothing you get nothing it
doesn't matter who you are too like Ben
Stiller is complaining about like I
can't get my numbers from Severance on
Apple so they're not in the business of
sharing that because that would probably
be leveraging a better deal for yourself
you know later on so
with a place like moment
the the two weeks or three weeks ends
and you get a data sheet with all the
emails maybe phone numbers wow
everything and also keep those emails or
is it like I'm sure they do yeah I'm
sure they have it in their database they
kind of want to be like they're they're
looking at like We're Young Turks in the
ticketmaster-ish lane where they want to
Aggregate and build up so that they can
then probably tell all their fans hey
Stevo's got a thing this week and Dane
Cook's got a thing next week yeah they
want to be able to like cultivate that
fan base with you so they're not just in
the actual digital media side of it
they're actually participating somehow
in ticket sales on tour not really yet I
don't think they have that full
bandwidth in place right now they just
they set up that opportunity take their
fee there's no there's no ownership over
your content there's nothing to do with
your IPS your IP all they're taking is a
couple of dollars off of whatever you
set the charge to be to keep it on their
server to have robust chats happening in
real time if people want to do that the
experience has been really really great
and the the the quality of it has been
really really uh well received is the
price on moment uh the same as what it
will be at danecook.com it'll probably
be twenty dollars at danecook.com
because I want to throw in some extra
you know I might be signing everything I
would throw in like I like to always
throw in like uh secret swag where you
don't really know what you're gonna get
with it so probably a little bit of an
uptick
um but I thought 15 was fair especially
when I saw Andrew Schultz who had also
gone the moment route and I thought like
I don't I just think that that's a good
number for what they're providing here
especially with the two dollar tag on so
it's it was you know like 17 bucks is it
downloadable when when you do it not on
their page through me it will be you'll
have that option but on moment it's just
on their server side and you can watch
it for as long as the moment is a moment
okay yes you can watch it for a moment
the streaming license does not uh
outlive the window that it
correct yeah at the end of that 14 days
it's just relates to you and then they
even said the next day you can you can
put it on YouTube you can give it away
you can do whatever you want on day 15.
Andrew Schultz heard that and he said
cool we'll do
right because he was like YouTube the
very next yeah afternoon one could argue
that uh that the people who paid 15
bucks to watch Andrew Schultz is special
like the World Cup shot on YouTube the
next day and we're maybe a little bit
pissed yeah but people like to get [ __ ]
first you know I think that there's a
premium for like being able to and maybe
talk about it maybe not plus uh the the
viewership he's gotten on YouTube is
staggering I would I would beg to Guess
that with him that that purchase was
also a show of like dude we want to put
you on the map that was like a show of
support versus
if uh you know somebody who's you know
Bill Burr did that he'd be like Bill did
you know two weeks later you're gonna
just give it away somebody like Schultz
at that pivotal moment of his come up
you know even though he's been coming up
for a while but like really took him to
another media level I thought it was a
smart play
um it was uh his operation is impressive
it was very yeah very yeah we went to
his uh studio and he's got a whole crew
of people yeah and he couldn't be nicer
I was gonna say in a good dude I mean he
texted him from the minute you know gave
his flowers and said dude congrats yeah
he you know we've kept in touch he's a
good guy you know you're rooting for him
and that's why his fans are supporting
him wherever he goes for sure for sure
yeah all of his people were like very
accommodating and like that's how you
know
good people doesn't he look like the
extra in every 70s movie though doesn't
he look like the guy that comes in with
a chip or information right yeah there's
just something about him like man it's
like he's like uh Nicholson in The
Shining like where he's in the picture
at the very end it's like I bet there's
like 50 pictures of Schultz in the 70s
yeah for sure it's reincarnated yeah
it's uh it's fascinating what's going on
in the [ __ ] world man it's like um
well some of these networks better get
their [ __ ] together or they're going to
be out of business get in the game yeah
they need to give it they need to be
like more like smaller Windows quicker
you know revert to IP to the artist
right otherwise they're they're gonna
miss this bus that's it I mean I I have
people I won't name names but I had
certain people right like why didn't you
meet with us first and I was like
because I know your contracts and
they're like that's not advantageous to
me or my fans who maybe at this point
don't want to buy your streamer because
they don't feel like there's the value
you in it the way they did and I'd
rather them just pay one-time fee can be
you know come to my gig and yeah well I
mean some of these [ __ ] like shows
like I mean how many views does Comedy
Central get you know what I mean with
400 000 right at most like if if and
then after it's had its little push it
just evaporates and no one can find it
I'll tell you I love what Spotify is
doing right now and actually quick plug
is my album goes on Spotify this week as
well
um and this is the name of this is above
it all yeah above it all and what I like
about Spotify is you can get you can
download
um uh Spotify for artists and that is a
a companion app it just goes right to
your page and it shows you in real time
everybody watching you know who's
whatever all that data is in real time
updating and that's kind of exciting to
like log in and be like this is where
everybody's enjoying this piece of
content right now I love that is the
audio version exclusive to Spotify that
and uh Apple iTunes okay yeah
all right
um dude so speaking of business right
like
is there another comedian who had the
the tenacity the entrepreneurial Spirit
to rent Arenas themselves like has
anybody ever done that and what what was
that even like Dan Cook might not say
this but I will it was baller as hell
what he did with the renting Arenas and
he's about to tell us how much money he
made and it's ridiculous you know what
else is ridiculous and not in a good way
the way that plastic is destroying the
world have you heard about what's going
on in the ocean they got like a big
block of plastic the size of Texas who
knows how big it is now I'm telling you
plastic is not good man and there's a
company that's bringing death to plastic
it's called liquid death this is a water
company if they've got your mountain
spring water from the Alps it's great
water it comes in infinitely recyclable
aluminum cans and man is this company
fun they make sure that they're
infinitely recyclable aluminum cans look
just like tall boys of beer they got
kids coming home from school with where
they're in trouble because the teacher
thinks they're drinking beer in class
the company loves it just a it's a lot
of fun I'm an ambassador of liquid death
I fully support this company and they
fully support the listeners of the Wild
Ride podcast by offering you an
incredibly generous deal where no matter
how much water or merch you order from
liquiddeath.com
Stevo you get free shipping it's crazy
like shipping especially water that that
costs a lot but they don't make you pay
at all free shipping for all of your
orders of water and merch and their
merchants hilarious too so go to
liquiddeath.com
Stevo for free shipping on all your
stuff and feel good about how you're
both saving the world by bringing death
to plastic and being a healthier person
by drinking more water
throw away the soda drink liquid death
yeah dude it's liquiddeath.com Stevo now
let's hear about all this money Dean
Cook made
the first time I rented Arena was
mid mid to late 2000s and it was really
because after everything that happened
with my brother I was in a real
bind
and I had everybody
um in my it's funny I had accounting and
people in my accounting who almost very
quickly were like don't need us anymore
I mean that's how setback I was it was
almost like we don't need to do any
accounting with you because you're kind
of at you know square one you told me
last night that you had just bought a
house and they were like hey they were
like you're gonna have to get out of
that house yeah it was it was two weeks
away from like paper or work being
signed and they were like no how old are
you oh
of like dyscalculus so sometimes numbers
I was 28. 29.
um and so they were like they were like
you know don't do this well I was like I
am going to keep this house it was my
dream house
and my idea was I had some money he
couldn't take that was in like some
stocks that just weren't easy to just
you know power of attorney out and I
took 450 000 which was pretty much
mostly all I had to my name
and I was like
how do you rent an arena and I started
calling Arenas basically just calling
and finding out it's just it's just a
haul right and when there's no game in
there it's just like except for a couple
of insurance things that you got to
cover back then maybe it's different now
it's like it's just a big Hall
especially B Arenas the big VFW I I
found that out so I rented uh I don't
remember the first two I rented but I
remember the door is mine the merch is
mine we did some deal on the on the um
you know food and drinks
and at the end of the two nights I'd
already put like a million eight or
something back in my pocket and I went
all right here's 200 000 rent me two
more that are within that range and we
just kept renting the B ones or maybe
even a C1 here or there packing it out
and then I kept renting them I probably
rented honestly like 80 Arenas on my own
and just was like by the end of the year
when I saw him in court I'd already made
everything back he stole it what took me
like 17 years I pretty much banked in a
year unbelievable
it's all right I think it was Barry Katz
told me about you renting Arenas yeah
and uh like is that is that a model that
anybody anybody else adopted no but I
know that other people you know they
just doing it now yeah but back then it
was like I knew it was uh of that level
and I'm like [ __ ] I I you know I want to
be there but I also don't want to I
can't split with anybody I don't want to
do any like
you know I don't want to do any I need
as much as what I can retain to get my
company and everything and be like you
know back with my head above water and I
also just had a personal grievance
against my brother that like just
completely honest I was like when I see
him a year from now in court I want to
[ __ ] look at him and say I have it
all back
I just wanted to be able to say I have
it all back I grieve into me in
resentment yeah I had like uh yeah I I
like a fire burning inside was there any
gratitude that if he never did that you
wouldn't start running 100 yeah Dane
told me that last night yeah I mean he
said had that not happened I would not
have reinvented myself you know why I'm
okay with it
because a past the Betrayal and
everything that breaks inside of you
when somebody you love does that betrays
with love work I mean betrayal is bad
enough betrayal with love
but I can actually look back and it's
like I got a lot of love from him I had
years of love with him there was great
memories there's things that I can still
look at and laugh I used to think he
rewrote my past there was an ERA I was
like I couldn't look at a picture
without being like that's not the
[ __ ] guy in the picture
and then just through doing the work
um and having great mentors and people
around me to help me it was like no I
had great years with him everything
happened the way it was supposed to
happen in order for me to really feel
um like I was standing on my own without
being shrouded in the negativity that
obviously he had around me for a lot of
years that I didn't know until it was
gone and once it was gone it was like oh
wow this is what it feels like to have
like you know clear air around you so
yeah it's like and I still have a great
relationship with his son I'm super
close with my nephew I love him it's
like everything that needed to come from
that did crazy so what uh is your
brother still in prison now no he served
for like five or six of eight years and
then he was released and he's never
taught no sense
poor guy yeah he learned a little bit on
that Comedy Tour man you jumped right on
the right side
sure is there uh in like the the justice
system for for that situation is there
like restitution or do they just say oh
yeah there's a [ __ ] out of money we
don't expect he could ever pay yeah so
it's like there's all these promises and
restitution in like the 48 charges or
whatever that he was brought up on
um you know equals like
a dollar a month that you get back at
some point somewhere but I honestly
looked at that and I was like whatever
the punishment is give it to them but uh
I there's nothing from that that I need
anymore right would you ever see him
again and be like dude we're cool I will
tell you this because I have to be
careful what I talk about at this point
I'm working on a documentary with a
great group of people right now and it's
really about that era the highest of
highs of how did I do what's my
philosophy and how did I get there and
stand up and really what is the cool fun
funny [ __ ] that happened and then the
other side is talking about my brother
it's like The Empire Strikes Back of
of comedy series and if I do it right
and if I answer your question in some
regard uh when this is on a streamer
maybe or if it is it should be either
under comedy or true crime or maybe both
yeah that's kind of where I wanted to
live like dude that was [ __ ] funny
but that was [ __ ] up that's hopefully
where I wanted to be dad cheer crime is
my [ __ ] that's mine too yeah damn it are
you familiar with JCS on uh YouTube no
oh my God
yeah it's criminal psychology I just
love I'll dial in on that I watch all of
that I'm still watching like old
Forensics Files
particular bangers okay cool okay all
right episode nine yeah do you feel like
uh do you feel like you had a lot like
when you had that hate inside of you you
had a lot of like energy blocking you
from like going forward in life and then
finally once you got over that like your
life started taking off again like do
you feel like there was some energy that
held you back and once you're able yeah
oh for sure I was in the undertow moment
for you know a few years because ready
uh it wasn't hate it was like
humiliation it was humiliation was the
number one thing because oh this is
tough tonight we grew up in a household
that because of my dad's alcoholism
there was a lot of humiliation attached
to his behaviors and so that was the key
word like we got to look like we're cool
because you know my mom and I were like
oh we don't want to we don't want people
to be able to like take our power with
this even though we already knew the
neighborhood knew and I think there was
just a whole thing of like
I thought I'd presented myself in my
life and career as like ah this is a
what self-made looks like and then he
made me look or feel at that time stupid
like I'd made the worst decision and I
knew some people were using that like
weaponizing that and saying like oh
you're not as smart as you have claimed
to be by getting to where you did so
yeah it was more
like it was like humiliation coupled
with
the inevitable come down of a career at
the same moment that that was all kind
of like happening
so it was like oh man this feels even
more like they're pushing me down the
hill even though I could look back later
and be like no I had my run and it was
awesome but but you're back and you feel
better like what happened to get you to
like oh man I just I love stand up I
love making people I'm at my core I just
love making people laugh I love I'm very
curious person and I love getting on
stage I'm a Storyteller I love improv I
I love human behavior I like
conversations that can be real and
gritty and I wanted to be able to take
stand up into more places than I had
taken it when I when I hit I had like
six tools pretty sharp but I was like
I'm still lacking in so many things that
I wish I was better at and it took me
more years to get like what does that
mean like I want to be more
introspective I knew some things that I
needed better in my storytelling I I
wanted to be more uh transparent about
like failure equal to like
um not just going up there and being
like look what I did how cool is that
like being able to go up and be like
here's the [ __ ] sandwich that I ate and
and I ate every bite and when you could
talk about all those things it's just
such a different
it permeates the world in a different
way because now your laughter is
Meaningful but your poignancy is
Meaningful and then and then from that
all I've all I've had the opportunity to
share in like thousands of versions of
this now where it's like I've grown up
with people that are like hey man I'm
glad we keep each other in check your
comedy keeps me in check your truth
keeps me in check just a nice place to
be and it's a nice place when you meet
somebody like him to wear
um Gilchrist
where somebody knows I don't want
anything from you I don't need anything
from you I just want to share a little
something with you it's a really great
feeling especially in the industry when
you meet somebody you know that's what
Jerry Lewis was for me when I met Jerry
Lewis he became like a mentor in many
ways like a father figure he didn't want
or need anything from me and it was just
such a valuable correspondence and
currency of conversation with him and
that's what I want to be able to be in
my comedy and just
you know in real time yeah with anybody
with any of my relationships yeah
is it safe to say that
like the the comedians that have risen
to the level of selling out arenas
like before you Andrew Dice Clay was at
that level Steve Martin
right that
comedy in arenas is like not sustainable
comedy arena is an event and people come
to be part of like drinks and craziness
and listening to the album on the way in
and whatever happens in the room they're
gonna get pieces of it because in most
places the sound is going to be
questionable right but it's an event I
always looked at every comedy every
poster was like a Dean Cook event comedy
in a theater definitely comedy in a club
or any comedy in the Park it's a
different gear altogether it has
different poignancy meaning and it isn't
to say that some of the people that
we're now seeing that have hit those big
time shows like uh fluffy like he's an
example of like he's tremendously
hilarious doesn't matter if it's small
Crowder or he you know he built an act
for that I built an act for that but for
the average comic it's not the best way
to say like here let me bring you to a
quiet moment within that story like you
better go out there and you're swinging
for the fences pretty much with
everything in that routine on that night
but you're not listening to hecklers in
an arena I got I got hecklers but like
you can't even address it right because
it's so [ __ ] like a right what's the
difference between a Heckler and a
theater and a Heckler Arena are you
still addressing like hey get this
[ __ ] guy out of here I had well I was
College age with college type hecklers
and they would like run up and try to
[ __ ] dive bomb the stage I had a dude
next to me take a shirt I'd be like and
in front of 20 000 people I just hear
him he's like he goes let's trade shirts
let's trade shirt and they scream and
I'm like and then security runs up and
pulls up and he pulls down the stairs
the guy's bouncing on the stairs what I
would do I remember like if somebody in
the nosebleeds heckled me dude I was
like I would do a thing where I would
look up like I could see you and I'd be
like hey dude I'm gonna get to that in a
second all right and I'd make you
[ __ ] believe I do see you I couldn't
see [ __ ] it's like I'm staring into a
light but I would do everything in my
power to be like I gotta Corral and keep
these people like tethered and then when
I get off at the end go oh my God that
was like yeah yeah I mean you can't get
affected by it right no but you have to
let them believe comedy whether no
matter the size of the room is all about
control they need to believe that you're
at the helm in those big shows same
thing that'll get away from you pretty
quick and I'm sure we've seen some of
those shows too it's gnarly
yeah
performing comedy
it's just it's such a [ __ ] vulnerable
art it's like you know like a painting
on the wall is so vulnerable to somebody
just coming up with a marker can of
spray paint you know and it's like
vandalism so vulnerable to [ __ ]
vandalism and that's what a heckling is
people yelling [ __ ] out they're
vandalizing their performance and it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] I saw Carrot Top perform
in Vegas yeah a few days it did great
great job yeah great show great guy
great guy he uh had a some he had
somebody Heck on there good wow and he
just he just goes
he goes oh hey I'm not busy I'm not busy
right now
it was so [ __ ] masterful it's
hilarious like I'm not busy right now
come on let's talk let's talk about this
it's so great watching the comic in that
moment what unfolds take notes on how to
respond
you just hear the mic drop he's like
everybody hates you
okay all right if you knew how much I
hate you and then he wears a 12-step
program so then he apologizes five
minutes later
you know I love it or he's like yeah I
want this guy out of here and then all
the security guards go over to the guy
he's like no no no no wait wait we can
keep the guy here and now it's just a
[ __ ] tense moment yeah I was gonna
say like where you're at now because
you're how many years in it's I've been
it's been 12 years since you and I did
The Improv that 12 years in and I mean
aside from obviously you're having
incredible success but like I said at
year 15 I still felt like there was a
lot of things I didn't know like where
are you at in terms I know what you're
strong at but like where do you where do
you kind of want to grow out that
experience on stage besides not dealing
with hecklers in the right way uh yeah
it's just that it accumulates over time
it builds up it builds up and then it
gets to a point where the littlest chirp
and you're like or it's like you tell
people not to record during the show
then it's right when he walks out you
just see a light right at the thing
right where do I want to grow in my
comedy
um
I would say writing you know like I'm
about to uh wrap up the tour I'm on and
and put together my next hour yep how
many dates was it how many dates was the
tour oh this one oh [ __ ] well it was
like a year before like six months
before the pandemic started this tour
before the pandemic oh okay so uh yeah
I've been hitting it hard and it's been
this Evolution with like bits getting
kicked out and everywhere in North
America they've been yeah we've been
everywhere in North America for sure
except Boise Idaho
um and uh
[Music]
um
I'm really challenging myself with the
next hour I'm gonna put together okay
like like really uh challenging myself
to tell them what you're gonna do
well you don't want to let the cat out
of the bag I'm sure but like oh it's out
it oh it is I mean it's going to be
called the gone too far tour okay I'm
gonna like like obliterate the lines and
go way too far
um there's need more of that one of the
tent pull bits is gonna be uh actual
breast augmentation surgery
the doctor tells me that I can go double
D
yeah I'll be buying a ticket for that
one
are you gonna do a mean greet topless I
don't know I don't know that I'll be I
think I'm likely to be restored back to
normal before the tour actually
commences you have to sign your own tits
at some point
that's a Rite of Passage
yeah that type of beer like we're
writing for that one yeah and uh I mean
yeah just writing you know that's uh
that's what what I want to do I want to
like make it masterful right like it's
like you know I mean I remember like two
sorry
same question to you what do you what do
you want to work I'm gonna say 2011 was
a year that I when I started I was uh I
felt like I had done so many things in
terms of like what I wanted to do with
physical comedy improvisational comedy
storytelling comedy but where I wanted
to it really accentuate is I wanted to
really learn Stillness on stage I wanted
to be able to have that so 2011 like the
first day of the year or January first
second or third I go I'm Gonna Stand
plant my feet and I'm not gonna move for
a [ __ ] year
and I spent all of 2011 basically for
the most part at the not even taking
like I was like challenging myself
to go I need to be able to tell
everything from right here and trust me
it was different some nights I was like
I just wanted to take it and walk or
prowl the stage or do whatever
but I really hung in there because I
wanted to be able to be cool in the
pocket because I knew if I could get
that and get my breathing okay in that
moment then I could I could bring a
story from like the hundred down to like
zero it even in above it all there's
like two moments
where you know I'm on my front porch we
filmed this at my house in the Hollywood
Hills and I let the entire thing just go
down to like the sound of people
listening and waiting for me
to you know come back with whatever the
next portion of the story is and I
wanted that so bad and after that year I
could finally say that was probably the
hardest thing I I will ever do in
comedies learn Stillness damn I'm a
walker yeah naturally I love it but I
wanted to be able to do that not all the
time but I wanted to be able to know I
could stop and just say now let me tell
you something this is the truth and
you're not going to interrupt me you're
not going to Heckle me I just want you
to hear me out on something and now I do
that and I do it easily but I couldn't
do that in like oh five to I'd still be
like
I'd be like doing this [ __ ] I'm so sorry
um you told me last night that you were
that there was a point where you wanted
to film a special on your [ __ ] front
porch yeah I had no idea that you were
telling me that that's what you did yeah
okay so and and by the way apologies for
not having uh bend a moment and consumed
this special I should have but this
happened so quick though we were at
dinner last night and then he's like
swing by I would have sent you the link
and showed it to you but yeah last night
we just had dinner and I was like you
know what we could probably pull this
together make it happen tomorrow
yeah I mean we had a [ __ ] day today
though so you probably didn't have you
didn't have 10 minutes to yourself yeah
it's uh that's true I filmed it on my
porch at the same house that I thought I
was going to lose I actually stand in
one point not that you would know this
unless you're now understanding of it I
stood in the exact spot that I sat with
my brother two weeks before I ended up
putting him in jail basically he was
with me and I was like can I buy this
house he was like of course he was like
teaming me up for like the ultimate like
you know dive bomb and so standing in
the exact spot in what I think is my
most kind of
for me I guess I can say like I feel
very uh fulfilled with every element of
this special
and I made sure to stand right in that
spot and deliver a piece of information
at some point so where's the audience
how many on my front lawn about a
thousand people we we've they built
Rafters shut up they built Raptors on my
lawn yeah Marty culner who directed
vicious circle and isolated dude that's
insane yeah dude you put your address
out there for people it was already on
[ __ ] Google and I knew people already
had it priorities there was already
drones just pictures of my [ __ ] Zillow
already [ __ ] lowballed my the price
of my home
um but I was like you know dude I just
wanna I wanna do something that um
I wanted to do something that was
bombastic and big
with the drones and Marty and and what I
knew would look like you know uh
shooting up there with the whole
Hollywood in front of me but I also
wanted to be really small and intimate
and personal so I think it's the biggest
and smallest comedy special ever created
yeah it sounds unbelievable to me uh did
you do two shows and yeah I did Friday
night but I nailed everything I really
wanted in an hour and 40 on Friday and
Marty turns to me that night and he goes
uh you didn't even hiccup it's like you
you really got it he's like I would do
two bits tomorrow night again and then
do whatever you want so I ran 240 the
second night and that was like a lot of
great banter pieces of material that
from before the pandemic that maybe I
didn't have a chance to you know figure
out where they belong so I'm editing
part two now wow from the same tonight
or the second night
in your editing it yourself
I I paused it now because at this point
I'm just trying to recoup what I spent
like that it's like I'm all in on my own
dime that's the other thing is like
people are like oh do you have investors
like no I own it a hundred percent
myself yeah so do I want to start
editing yes would I like to know I got a
few bucks back in the till
um which is looking pretty good then
that's where I need to start but
probably in the New Year put it together
part two
hmm your nephew ever sees your show Cody
yeah yeah I wanted him to come up to
this he couldn't come to this just
for covid uh certain restrictions and
stuff we had to do there but yeah he
comes to my shows a lot does he look
like his dad he does is it weird he's
got
um maybe the first couple of times yeah
but he's such a stud he's such a good
kid and uh that's cool you're still your
buds without oh hell yeah I was like I'm
not gonna let this relationship go
because of course not you know his dad's
stupidity yeah
I wanted to ask you about movies too
yeah I love doing them thank God you
know anybody who wants to throw a
[ __ ] 50 year old dude with half a
testicle in a new film I'm ready to go
what's happened testicle I mean I had an
undescended ball when I was born holy
[ __ ] yeah so the left one was like up
here and they can't bring that down
until you're like three or four years
old so the right one got big and then by
the time they pulled the left one and
pouched it the left one was like this
adorable little [ __ ] side item yeah
but my right ball is impressive
I wish I didn't step on that [ __ ]
that's exactly that's exactly it I love
film work though man I love it yeah I
mean you you uh yeah the grocery store
movie the uh
employee of the month with Dax yeah yeah
yeah important and then a movie that
you're like I don't even know if it's
gonna see the light of day like some
sometimes you make even though that was
my first one I was like I don't know if
the Lionsgate was a boutique company at
the time and I was like this is my first
leading role but I also don't know if
like these things always make it out it
was great yeah no it's got legs man
people write me about it every week oh
my family we still watch that we love it
so like I saw like two years ago again
yeah it's really it's a delightful movie
that holds up what was the one with
Jessica Simpson that's what that's it
that's it yeah employee of the month was
Simpson Good Luck Chuck with Alba and
Kate Hudson came in and did Best
Friend's Girl and she was like comedic
royalty she she was like amazingly funny
Kate Hudson was unbelievable out of all
the celebrity females that I've ever
seen in my life in real life yeah
Jessica Alba was the most beautiful
human being I've ever seen in person wow
yeah absolutely lovely that was a high
praise yeah do you have a uh he said
that like not every other man on the
planet would have been like yeah I've
seen her in person you know what I mean
like uh yeah who who is the best
on-screen kisser
the best on-screen kiss was probably
well actually he's probably Kate Hudson
because we were just having so much fun
on that movie and we were real Pals she
was actually dating Dax oh really so
crap they were together so he was
hanging around but like just our scenes
were it was just well written so kissing
and then some of the crazy [ __ ] we were
saying to each other in between just to
make each other laugh that was probably
the best experience everything else
feels weird man it always feels so
intrusive and strange and there's a guy
trying to light you and telling you like
I have a big Irish head so it's kind of
like my head next to Jessica Alba is
like I look like a [ __ ] rock creature
coming in like you know it's just all
really weird until it you see it and
then you're like all right next scene
let's go yeah
slot man I said dude I I saw when when
was it like you were on like was it
maybe Theo Von's podcast or something
like like a year or two ago and you're
like you were pretty big at that point
like and then you lost all this like
what
I lost weight it was a shitty thing to
ask how about yourself you're 15 you're
jacked no a couple things uh when I did
that podcast it's interesting because I
had um
gained a bunch of weight for a film that
never ended up happening right to play
like a wrestler who like was you know
whatever so I put on a bunch of weight
and then I did some HGH which I'd never
done that before it's hormone yes and so
then I did that and dude it like well
the thing I didn't know about it is not
only did it like bulk me up but like it
bulks up your facial muscles and so
uh it's funny because I saw that podcast
recently now that was after I was coming
off of it but like the year before that
I almost like was unrecognizable even to
myself but I also just didn't feel when
I put the weight on that movie went away
and never ended up covered like
absolutely canceled it but then I was
like I want to get in the best shape of
my life heading to 50. so I started
swimming every day I have a swim tether
and I do like an 800 to a thousand
calorie swim every morning
and it like I I'm probably down about 25
pounds in the last like
you know weeks weeks fantastic right now
oh thanks bud I feel good you didn't why
didn't you do TR like testosterone why'd
you go to HGH you want to get big I just
went to a an organization that was like
oh we know the right you know way to get
you like and I was like yeah I want to
get like kind of like shredded but like
imagine a wrestler with Dad bod who's
still kind of like the wrestler like a
little bit of your look but still
and and I did it it was working fine but
then I just finally just did not look
like I didn't look healthy and I
definitely didn't look like myself and
there's pictures out to this day that
people sometimes send me and be like
dude what the [ __ ] did you do did you do
like plastic surgery and I'm like no I
just my like my jowls [ __ ]
you know got muscles on muscles so
um now it's just like I eat pretty well
and I just I swim I do my fiance does um
certified Pilates instructor so I do her
class twice a week I play with Harlem
Williams I play racquetball twice a week
and I swim every day wow yeah he's uh
he's a unique guy man I love him yeah
Harlem Williams I put in employ them up
and I put them in the movie because
again honestly I was like I don't know
if this movie's gonna I don't know how
this is gonna do yeah
um but I want to start myself with funny
people so at least I know that we're
being funny and I can look at it later
so I got Andy Dick in there I got Harlan
Williams
they were amazing they were incredibly
funny Dax brought so many ideas to the
table
um but was interesting but Harlan is for
10 years the Harlan I knew even leading
up to that movie was the Harlan I'm sure
you knew which is like he's just his
brain operates on a different level he
comes up with all this stuff off the
cuff and I would see him at the club for
years and when I'd come into the lobby
and I'd be kind of like when I'm off
stage I'm pretty like I'm just off I'm
like I'll be when I'm on when I'm on
stage some people are on all the time he
was on all the time hey there buddy I
want to tell
geez it's their buddy and crumple them
up in your hair and then I want to put a
sailor's hat on and then he'd make like
a and he'd do a weird sound he was like
that for years of me and I try to have a
normal conversation and every single
time I would ask him a serious question
he'd go into this character and then
after like 10 years and after the movie
I was in the lobby one night and I
remember he just walked in and I was so
used to it I was like hey what's up man
and he was like
how's it going there buddy and it was
like a different tone it was like after
12 years he finally broke character and
I was like Harland and he's like yeah
buddy you want to get dinner and he's
like yeah what do you what do you like
to eat and I thought he was gonna be
like I like Cheez-Its in the hair buddy
and then I'm gonna and after that our
friendship just like took off and he was
a real champion of mine no matter what
era I was in up or down that guy's
always been a real solid in my life I
love him yeah he and Tom Green are
really two peas in a pie another one I
love that guy man yeah great dude just
uh
it doesn't always need to be about show
business or comedy sometimes it's just a
nice word out of nowhere I like that
yeah yeah it's so epic yep cool all
right well we have uh some
some viewers to send to above it all
yeah I hope that they uh have a great
time with it I'm really really stoked
yeah
um
I wonder can we see your balls on a
camera see the right one the left one
fall asleep I put the left one a little
cozy
that's how [ __ ] like that one thought
it was on a solo Mission so it just like
was like all right I got this it's like
the twins in the belly one eight the
other one it got bigger yeah I describe
it as like uh the small one is the moon
of Endor and the big one's the Death
Star
them into it a little bit too much on
the visual on that one but all right
um quick question should we hold this
until uh the the week after October 26th
so that it's absolutely on
danecooked.com it'll be on danecook.com
for sure next Thursday Friday
I'm totally you know down with whatever
you guys want to do if you think it's
better for next week cool if you want to
hold it because your own agenda then
it's all good yeah I mean I don't even
have an agenda you know yeah I'm uh
I'm stoked we're good and uh and okay so
social media handles anything else that
we want to promote everything is uh
pretty much the Hub of all my social
media I like
tick-tocks if I still have my space I
wonder if it's still somewhere do you
think that I could somehow tell tequila
is still in there just walking around
sure
um I I wish it was someplace that you
could go in and you'd probably log into
those old messages
um everything is pretty much the Hub I
like Tick Tock because I like their Live
program yeah like when you go live you
feel like you're really your fans are
really finding you in real time so at
Dane Cook pretty much on everything but
Tick Tock is where it's at at Dean Cook
on all the social media platforms
danecook.com for the special and all the
other tour info for 2023 man I hope
we're crossing paths so we can check out
each other's gigs that would be really
fun above it all
is something it's it sounds so [ __ ]
crazy to film let's just edit that
you've already seen it and just be like
dude it's [ __ ] awesome I mean
whatever the best I've ever seen give me
that link and when I found the intro to
this podcast I can see I'll send it I
hadn't seen it before but I've seen it
yeah I'll send it tonight dude thank you
for uh the love and support over the
years and uh you look great thanks for
not gonna sound great you look great and
you're killing it so continued success
to you Wendy Scott thanks for having me
yeah thanks very much awesome
what's my cut
and I had Wendy the whole time
that was great that was fun oh man
yeah dude if you don't love Dan Cook now
then you're just a bad person because uh
what a great guy and again I cannot ever
stop feeling grateful for how much he
helped me launch what what's now a crazy
career in comedy I'm on my own tour bus
over here and and I credit Dan cook for
launching me onto this path really
really grateful for him and you know I'm
really really grateful for you
um Scott Randolph has been on tour with
me for uh you know the last week or so
and we keep saying it man something
about this podcast is is clicking it's
blowing up people are are hounding Scott
Randolph for photos
it's crazy chicks are like man I love
Scott Randolph
wow
she is single
um I am not
um I love you thank you for sticking
around to the end thank you to everybody
who uh mentions the street team after uh
my shows can't get enough of it super
grateful I love you all and thank you
for watching yeah